- Sanctions have finally
come for the Kraken,
and man, these ones are a doozy.
We've covered the case
of King versus Whitmer
in Michigan many times.
Last we left it, the city of Detroit
and the state of Michigan
were going after Sidney Powell
and her team Kraken wranglers
for sanctions for the cost of
going through the litigation
that was manifestly ridiculous.
Well, Judge Parker has
come down like a hammer
on Sidney Powell and her entire team.
They are going to have to pay
for the costs of litigation.
It's joint in several liability
against all of Sydney Powell's lawyers,
which means that the defendants
can get the entire amount
from any single one of the defendants
and it will be up to the defendants
to sue each other for only
their portion of the liability.
That's going to be fun to watch.
But the coup de grace
comes on the very last page
of this decision where
the judge basically refers
every single one of those attorneys
to the various states'
disciplinary committees,
basically hinting that she
wants all of them disbarred.
No lawyer ever wants to find
themselves in that situation.
So in the future,
we may never see any of
those people in court.